يعني معتاد من الجانب الروسي في كل مره
يفرض الغرب عقوبات جديده على روسيا كيف
تتعاطى روسيا مع هذه العقوبات
نعم اذا عدنا الى العقوبات الاخيره التي
تم الاعلان عنها هنا السلطات الروسيه تقول
انها ستدافع عن مصالحها بكل الاجراءات
الممكنه وترى ان هذه العقوبات المتواصله
لا تتماشى ربما مع القوانين الدوليه
بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك العديد من
المجهودات
الاقتصاديه التي تقوم بها روسيا لتفادي
تداعيات هذه العقوبات ولذلك هناك تشديد
على اهميه هذا الخطاب الذي سيلقيه الرئيس
بوتين غدا والذي سيتطرق ايضا وفق بعض
المحللين لهذه العقوبات ولكيفيه تجاوز هذه
العقوبات عبر اجراءات جديده عموما هذه
العقوبات في هذه السنه الاولى لم تؤثر
بذلك الشكل الذي كان متوقع بعد سلسله من
العقوبات المتواصله على قطاع النفط وعلى
العديد من القطاعات الحيويه في روسيا
ابقى معنا ايمن بايدن يقول ان الاقتصاد
الروسيه تراجع وموسكو معزوله وبوتين كان
يراهن على عدم اتحاد الناتو
وحلفاء اوكرانيا اذا هذه من التصريحات
التي ادلى بها اليوم الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن فادي انتقل اليك مساعدات جديده اذا
لاوكرانيا اعلن عنها الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن اليوم وقال بان الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي
في دعم اوكرانيا
رئيس بايدن يتحدث عن مساعدات بقيمه نحو
500 مليون دولار تحدث عن عدد منها مثل
صواريخ جاب ليل وغيرها من الامور لكنه لم
يبدو انه اعلن عن اي اسلحه جديده بانتظار
صدور تفاصيل هذه الحزمه الجديده من قبل
وبذلك لتتجاوز المساعدات العسكريه
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا منذ بدايه الحرب قبل
نحو عام من الان نحو 30 مليار دولار لكن
خلال حديثه مع الرئيس
انه جرى بحث ايضا مساله الصواريخ بعيده
المدى التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا بشده كما
تقول القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه للتعامل
مع الغزو الروسي على اراضيها كما تقول لكن
في هذا السياق ليس ليس هناك اي اعلان
حقيقي بالنسبه لمساله الاتحاد الجمهوري
والديمقراطيه هذه الحزبين السياسيين خلف
جهود دعم اوكرانيا هناك لا شك دعم واسع
الطيف في الكونجرس لكن ايضا هناك خلافات
تحديدا من قبل موقف الجمهوريين القياده
الجمهوريه الجديده التي تسلمت رئاسه مجلس
النواب والسيطره على مجلس النواب بعدما
انتزعت السيطره عليه خلال الانتخابات
مصريه الماضيه هي لا تريد ان تريد ان تمنح
الاداره الامريكيه تفويضا مفتوحا فيما
يتعلق بهذه المساعدات كما سبق ان اعلن
الرئيس الحالي لمجلس النواب مكارسي وهناك
بعض الاصوات المعترضه ايضا على استمرار
هذه المساعدات ولكن تظل في جناح يميني
متطرف يرى ان هناك هدف لهذه الاموال في ظل
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه التي تعيشها الولايات
المتحده تحديدا مساله التضخم لكن في كل
الاحوال الرئيس بايدن اراد ان يبعث برساله
وحده وراء اوكرانيا حتى وان كانت
الاستطلاعات الراي في الداخل الامريكي
تشير الى تراجع الدعم الشعبي الامريكي
لاوكرانيا في اخر استطلاع للرائعه على
سبيل المثال مركز وكاله
مع نورك وهو مركز ابحاث موجود في جامعه
شيكاغو اظهر هذا الاستطلاع تراجع تاييد
الشعبيه الامريكيه لاستمرار مساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا من 60% في مايو العام
الماضي اي بوعيد بدايه الحرب الى نحو
ثمانيه واربعين في المئه عشيه دخول هذه
الحرب عامها الثاني وبالتالي هناك فارق
كبير في الدعم ولكن الرئيس بايدن في كل
الاحوال من خلال هذه الزياره الروس السريه
على اعتاب الذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا كان واضحا بانه يريد ان يبعث
برساله بان الكلام الان وتحديدا الرئيس
بوتين الذي كان يعتقد ان مساله اخضاعك سوف
تكون نزهه بالنسبه لقواته العسكريه التي
عبرت الحدود بيلاروسيا باتجاه قياس الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير لم تصمت فقط وتدفع
القوات الروسيه الى التقهر بل ان كان
يفترض ان تكون تحت سلطه الكلام هي الان
مفتوحه لزياره الرئيس الامريكي وليس فقط
ليهن الشعب الاوكراني على ما تمكن من
القيام به بل ايضا لتاكيد توفير مساعدات
عسكريه جديده تساهم في قتال اوكرانيا ضد
القوات الروسيه وساهمت اولا في حمايه
اكياب ودفع القوات الروسيه للاستحاب تحرير
جزء اراضي من اراضي من خرسان وايضا الصمود
في وجه الهجوم الروسي في شرق روسيا كل هذه
هي رسائل لا شك انها سوف تصل بشكل واضح
للكريم هي رساله التحدي ولكن ايضا رساله
يفتتح بها بايدن الذكرى او عشيه الحرب في
عامها الثاني ليقول ان هذا الدعم سوف
يستمر مباشره ليس فقط من قبل الولايات
المتحده بل ايضا من حضور الرئيس الامريكي
شخصيا على اراضي العاصمه على الحدود
المباشره لروسيا عند الجار الروسي
الاوكراني وليقول ان الدعم للولايات
المتحده سوف يستمر النيتو متحد امن اوروبا
سوف يؤمن ولم يسمح لروسيا بان تنتهك سياده
اوكرانيا وبان تغير القواعد والقوانين
الدوليه في ده